[Music]
the longest ride is the latest in the
long string of Nicholas Sparks
adaptations he's the writer who has made
so many romance novels and they've all
turned into romance movies and they all
have the exact same poster including the
longest ride and they all kind of have a
checklist of sorts there's always a love
story with two young people who for some
reason can't be together for some reason
there's usually an older person who's in
love or was in love or they're both in
love one person has Alzheimer's one
person can't remember something somebody
eventually dies there's usually a war
involved or letters like in Dear John
and someone finds those letters and
reads them and we cry and it's emotional
and blah blah blah they're all the same
why did I see this movie because it's
like the only wide release out this
weekend Thanks
now at two hours and 19 minutes the
longest ride is a perfect title for this
movie there were many times where I just
almost left I was so tempted to leave
but I sat there and I watched the entire
thing Scott Eastwood plays a bull rider
he's a very good bull rider and he's
getting to the point where he might be
injuring himself this is Clint
Eastwood's son and my goodness do they
look alike
now Scott Eastwood has shown himself in
the past to be talented and you know
what he's good in this movie in fact
most of the stars are really good in
fact it's a well-directed movie for the
most part it's all shot well it looks
nice the cinematography is good this is
the kind of movie that can trick you
into thinking it's a good movie until
you examine it at its very core and you
realize that it's just the exact same
movie we've already seen a million times
before just repackaged in a different
structure Britt Robertson is coming up
in this year's Tomorrowland which I'm
really looking forward to she's also
good in the movie but there are times
where I think she's a little over the
top that could have been the direction
that could have been how they wanted her
character to be Scott Eastwood was a lot
more subtle and subdued and she was kind
of too much at times I think that she is
a good actress and I'm looking forward
to seeing what she does in Tomorrowland
but it was probably just her character
like her reactions just felt like movie
reactions you know like not real-life
reactions just like oh my gosh in a
movie I got to make everything really
big and she was just too
larger-than-life I think in this film
Alan Alda is a fantastic actor and he
does a very good job with what he's
given in this movie but you just
and justify this movie because it's the
exact same as all of the other Nicholas
Sparks movies it's like when you walk
into a Michael Bay movie you know
exactly where you're going to get a lot
of explosions ass shots and like high
contrast saturated colors and low framed
angles of people stepping out of cars in
a Nicholas Sparks movie you're going to
get old people talking about when they
were young and they first met and how
sad and tragic that is young people who
want to fall in love but can't because
something's in the way whole bunch of
flashback sequence is probably a war
scene or two and somebody reading a
letter that's very sad and we get
narration we're supposed to cry and it's
all terrible but it's just boring as
hell the longest ride I'm not going to
spend any more time talking about this
movie I'm going to give this film a
d-plus it's the same as every Nicholas
Sparks movie but it does have the added
benefit of not having a romantic spirit
ghosts giving someone advice yeah that
happened in another one of his movies
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you missed my reviews
for Lost River Ryan Gosling's first
directorial feature as well as my first
in my Tom Cruise series of movie reviews
mission impossible both of those are on
my channel right now if you'd like to
check those out
I am also running a new promotion right
now that I'd love to tell you guys about
it's hard to get a job trust me I know I
had like ten of them throughout my
teenage years and that's why I wanted to
work with zip recruiter if you go to zip
recruiter comm slash Chris you can apply
to hundreds of different jobs in one
place for free millions of people are
doing this and it's helping a lot of
people find work and I think that's
really awesome health care sales all
different types of things retail I
really think it's great and that's why
I'm doing this it's not movie related I
just really like the fact that I see
other people out there actually trying
to help other people find employment
because I know that's a hard thing to do
right now and that's why I wanted to do
this promotion so go to zip recruiter
comm slash Chris and you can apply to
hundreds and hundreds of different jobs
don't see the longest ride though not
really worth your time as always thank
you so much guys for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck Munoz
[Music]